Up devs feeling the strain.
Headless browsers causing you pain.
Memory
hogging oh so slow.
Got your automation losing its flow.
Scraping sites
quickest headless you've ever seen.
Yeah. It's the Rawkode stream. Tune right in.
Got Pierre and Katie, let the show begin.
Introducing LightPanda.
Yeah. Built with six so keen
LightPanda.
Woah. The fastest on the scene. Let's ram
more speed. A developer's dream. Live on Rawkode.
Join the stream.
Forget the bloat, the startup lag.
Light pandas here, it's in the bag.
10 times faster light on the RAM, open
source of power, part of the plan.
See the live demo, watch it blast, and
get the quick start, make your scripts last.
In the banging J and S game,
it's the Rawkode stream to Riot in. Got
Pierre and Katie, let the show begin.
Introducing LightPanda.
Hell. Built with zigs so keen.
LightPanda,
the fastest on the scene. Less RAM, more
speed, a developer's
dream. Live on Rawkode,
join the stream.
Plug in puppeteer,
play right to.
Your old code, swap the engine through. Hear
the road map, what's coming next. Making machine
browse less complex
with Pierre
and Katie
right here.
Light panda's future is crystal clear
on Rawkode
Academy.
Learn and
Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, sometimes known across
the Internet as Rawkode, and this is an
episode of Rawkode Live where we take a
look at the coolest
cloud native and adjacent software projects, particularly open
source, to make your life all that little
bit easier. And today, we're taking a look
at a new browser on the scene. This
one, a headless browser to make your tests
and AI workloads faster.
I am joined by two members of the
LightPanda team, Pierre and Katie. Hi there both.
How are you?
Hey, David. Hello. Good to be here. Yeah.
Yeah. Welcome. It's an absolute pleasure to sit
down and have a conversation and take a
look at interest in tech. It's always the
absolute highlight of my day.
So before we talk about LightPanda and what
you're building, can you both take a minute
just to say hello and introduce yourself to
the audience, please?
Sure. So
I'm Katie. I'm the co founder and COO
at LightPanda.
And
I've known Pierre and our other co founder,
Francis, for the last eight years. We worked
together before in our previous company where we
were doing a ton of web scraping.
And
LightPanda was born very much from that pain
as we'll have time to talk about.
Yeah. Hello. So I'm Pierre. Nothing more to
add
really. I'm the CTO.
Happy to be here and happy to show
you what the browser can do.
Awesome.
I think this will be a great episode
and interest in technology. This is something that
anyone who has built a website or built
any kind of web screen or, you know,
things that need the browser to do whatever
they're doing. I felt the pain in Puppeteer
and Playwright. And it's not that those are
not great tools. It's that the underlying browser
technology, headless Firefox and headless Chromium.
In fact, all Chromiums, headless or not. Right?
They are a sucker for our CPU and
their memory consumption.
And I think it's nice that we get
to take this opportunity to see what you've
been building and hopefully make this a lot
easier for everyone else.
Now I know that we have some slides.
Katie, if you wanna share those up and
we can, you know, dive straight into it
and talk about Panda in more detail.
Yep. Sure.
That again?
Yep. I can see the LightPanda logo. It
is awesome. Please take it away.
Alright. So, yeah, I'm not gonna take too
much time on this part, but we just
wanted to give a little bit of background
on the project and
how it was
born, how we're thinking about the space that
we're building in.
So I mentioned that we all worked together
in the past and we were doing a
bunch of web scraping.
And web scraping has been around for a
really long time. So if we look
back to the very first web pages,
some of you may remember them. They were
way more basic
HTML type
web pages.
Today the
internet and the web is really a dramatically
different place
where you
have
full applications running within web browsers.
And so the
web browser itself has had to massively evolve
to support that transition.
Two thirds of the traffic today goes through
Google Chrome and Chrome
is
running under the Blink rendering engine, which was
developed in 2013 and is actually a fork
of WebKit, which is the rendering engine behind
Safari,
which itself
is a fork of KHTML,
which is
the engine behind Conqueror, which is now deprecated.
So as you were saying, there's nothing fundamentally
wrong with this
code. It's just not at all built for
the automation use cases that it's
now being used for. And
there is now a need, we think, for
something fundamentally different.
The web browser itself,
this is the kind of architecture of a
standard web browser that humans would use your
own or desktop or our phone.
Essentially, without going into too much more detail
here,
a collection of different elements that enable a
human to interact with a web page. There
are hundreds of web APIs and more and
more developed every day to support the increasing
complexity complexity of the web.
And
so we were talking about scraping 50%
of the traffic that goes to the web
today comes from machines,
and that's not a new phenomenon at all.
It feels like we're talking about it a
lot more at the moment because of
AI use cases, which are coming to the
fore, but it's actually been that way for
the past five plus years that it's been
half the web traffic.
And that's coming predominantly from
things like indexing for SEO, more traditional scraping
use cases, like what we were doing at
our previous company, which was an e commerce
kind of intelligence
platform where we were scraping
retail product pages.
And then obviously everything that's emerging now around
AI, so extracting data to train models,
chatbots that are calling the web in real
time to provide
information to users
and agents,
of course, as well.
And so
when we think about how we automate the
web,
just as the web pages themselves have changed
the way
that we automate it and the tools that
we use to automate the web have changed
as well.
Back in the 2000s,
you could just do a simple HTTP request
or a colon, it would be enough to
get the vast majority of data within a
web page.
And the problem that we're faced with now
is that
there is JavaScript
absolutely everywhere all over the web, probably somewhere
around 40%
plus of the
content on the web lives in JavaScript,
and you can't access that content unless you
have a web browser to execute the JavaScript.
And so that's the kind of hack, I
guess, that developers are living with today,
is they're using
what's called a headless web browser. So essentially
all the same architecture under the hood,
just not
the GUI, the graphical user interface
that humans see, but everything else exactly the
same.
And
you can use
these testing frameworks that you may recognise are
on the side puppet of PayWrite or Selenium
to programmatically control
a headless web browser.
For the
large majority, it's headless Chrome,
and that kind of does the job, quote
unquote.
But we think that, and having done this
at scale in our previous company, we were
scraping around about 20,000,000 web pages a day,
and we really felt the pain firsthand of
that.
For about 90% of our use cases at
the time, we didn't need this block of
the rendering engine
on the left hand side.
And so that's
really what we're doing
at LightPanda.
Is just an interesting quote actually as we
start thinking about the AI use cases
that Vercel published at the end of last
year saying
on their network,
all of these major AI crawlers,
firstly, they represent about a third of Google
bots volume already. So that's huge when you
think that they didn't exist a couple of
years ago.
And also none of them are rendering JavaScript,
which is
we can assume because to run a real
web browser at that scale is computationally just
super expensive.
So yeah, this is what we're doing at
LightBand and we're gonna go into it way
more in-depth, so I won't spend much time
here, but we've removed the rendering engine on
top of the GUI.
But we have, other than that, a full
web browser with all the rest of the
components that you see here, including JavaScript execution
and a CDP server, which means you can
plug it into the puppeteers and the playwrights
of the world.
We launched our beta at the end of
last year, it is still in beta,
the first results show that
it's 10 times faster and uses 10 times
less resources
than headless Chrome.
And that is effectively a multiplication because with
the same amount of resources, you're able to
do 100x more with LightPanda than with Chrome.
So that's us in a nutshell. I'm gonna
stop sharing now, and we can
dive more into it.
Great. Thank you.
Look.
The AI traffic is obviously super pertinent right
now. Now I've got a whole bunch of
domains because I'm just one of those developers,
and some of these domains have never had
anything on them or haven't been updated in
five plus years.
But my HTTP server logs show that my
traffic in those last five years has increased
substantially.
Like, these unknown domains I don't use for
literally anything
are getting tens of thousands of hits every
single month. And
I can imagine there's not one real human
there.
And that's not even domains that are, like,
the rock of the kind of website or
maybe the news. Things are updated on a
near daily basis. They're probably getting scraped much
higher intervals because there's context there. That's how
these AIs,
whether it be AI search engines or model
training, etcetera, stay relevant. It's
just that I'm in a traffic alone. I
think at this time being prepared I mean,
it didn't really exist beyond Googlebot, like you
said,
more than five years ago before this AI.
Just bewilders me. I can't believe this is
where we are today, but at the same
time, we use AI every single day as
well. It's been part of the problem, I
would imagine. But it it it it helped.
I'm curious about building your own engine here.
And, obviously, there are a whole bunch of
web engines that exist. There's there's Chromium. We
know that's slow. There's Gecko from Firefox.
I think it's, you know, a lot of
legacy code also quite slow.
There was the server spin off project from
Mozilla, which I think now lives as an
open source project.
I know the Ladybug browser team are building
their own engine.
Now, obviously, Servo and Ladybug are built with
the rendering engine and the fact that there
will be a UI in front of it.
It's a a consumer engine. But I guess
the question here is,
what's different about building a browser without a
rendering engine and what
you know, I'm assuming there's trade offs that
you're able to
what's the word? Take advantage of because you're
you're cutting out this bit. It makes it
I don't know if it's easier to write
word or just better, but let's go into
that in a bit more detail.
Tell me why you build your own engine
instead of using the cloth shells components and
what you can do better because of these
constraints.
Well,
obviously, it's not easy to create a browser
or to write a browser from scratch.
That's a lot of work. But
at the beginning,
we would prefer to just take, let's say,
Chromium and remove the rendering parts and just
using it to, well, run what we want.
So don't rewrite from scratch and remove just
the rendering.
But
the issue was
it's not really possible because
the rendering
elements are
everywhere
in the code, in fact. Everything you are
doing,
it's related to the rendering.
So you can't just
cut it simply. You have to almost change
in every layer in
the browser to remove the rendering things.
So it wasn't
really possible to
do that simply to do a real headless
browser. So as Katie said, by headless browser,
we say that we will not
render graphically
the web page.
And that's
something which is done by Chromium even with
the headless options.
So the rendering is done in memory, it
just never display in the screen. So all
the work is done. In fact, that's why
you can do screenshots
or PDF with
Chrome
headless.
The idea for us, it was to just
avoid all this work and that wasn't possible
using an existing browser. It's the same. So
Servo,
as you said, is a rendering
engine. So it was the same. Everything was
merged everywhere.
But also the
ladybirds
do the same, exactly
same thing. So everywhere
in the code you have rendering code to
remove if you want to change that. So
that's why we started from scratch,
in fact.
Also,
Sorry. Go ahead. Can clarify
something? So I just wanna make sure I
have a good understanding of this in my
head. Right? When we're talking about rendering engine,
I'm assuming there's still a DOM and the
JavaScript is still run and the DOM is
manipulated, but there's no there's just no visual
representation of that. Right? That's how you're able
to, you know, run Gmail or whatever. And
while you click on buttons or see anything,
the the DOM is being manipulated. You can
fetch data. You can run tests against assertions
and all of that other really important stuff
as well. Yes. Yes, that's the goal. Yeah.
We want to take
the
difference between us and let's say, curl is
that we want to
fetch the HTML,
the raw HTML, and then fetch all the
resources, the JavaScript resources, and
be able to run the JavaScript
of the page.
And then
what we render, in fact, is the final
HTML. So the HTML, the DOM, which has
been modified by the JavaScript.
So we
want to execute XSHARE,
change, update the DOM,
create the new HTML tags, etcetera. So we
don't do graphical rendering,
but we do
actually execute the JavaScript and
generate the final DOM of the web page.
Okay. And are you building your own JavaScript
runtime as well? Are you hooking into V
eight, spider monkey? Like, what what's going on
behind the the hood there? No. No. We
are we are using v eight, actually. So
it was well, yeah. We
we want to do the minimum work
we can.
So reusing existing
JavaScript engine was the simplest things to do.
V eight is used by
many user projects
and well integrated.
It gave us an idea on how we
can bind ourselves to this JavaScript. And
in fact, it's a really important
element in the browser but we are trying
to
stay
the most decoupled
from the JavaScript engine we can because we
have the idea maybe in the future to
be able to
unplug V eight and plug another JavaScript engine.
Let's say we would like to be able
to plug
QuickJS,
for example,
which is the smallest JavaScript engine,
but in full C,
which could allow
us to
maybe have a smaller binary
in the future,
which is something
which could be interesting
depending the use case we can
offer, in fact.
But yeah, yeah, it is the main element.
All right. We do have a question in
the chat, so I'm gonna throw it up
just now to tackle this one early.
But PyTraderDetective,
wonderful name there.
Heard us mention Puppeteer, Playwright, and Selenium, and
they're curious which one is most compatible with
LightPanda. And I'm gonna push that a bit
further and let's not I mean, like, we
can talk about compatibility,
but used to know this space. So let's
get some opinions. Right? Which which one would
you use and why?
Which one?
I my personally, I've I I'm more a
Go developer and I prefer to use a
Chrome DP, which is a Go client
for the CDP protocol and to control the
browser. So I'm more
But
now, in fact,
if I have to pick one,
will take Perpetr
because
Well,
to answer the question,
we are the most compatible
with Puppeter
actually.
We are working on the PreWrite compatibility but
we have issues mainly because,
well, to control the browser, Puppeter and PreWrite
are using CDP protocol,
which is the Chrome DevTool
protocol,
so specific to Chrome. And
this,
well, Chrome exposes
a CDP server, which is
a WebSocket HTTP server in the sole. And
so you can send a command
on it.
But
the Chrome DevTools protocol allow you to
achieve some actions in different ways. You can
run big chunk of JavaScript doing what you
want, executing in the browser in the context
of your page, for example, but you have,
obviously, specific
commands
you can run
on
the CDP.
There
are a lot of commands on it possible.
So depending on the clients,
can have to do the same thing. You
can have many strategies.
So
currently we are more competitive with Preparator,
but
Playwrights,
we have issues in fact.
And Selenium,
we don't support it for now at all
because it doesn't use
CDP at all. It use web driver,
which is another protocol. Maybe
we will implement it
in the future, but actually we don't.
Yeah. I mean, just to I mean, I
I'm not super knowledgeable on this space. But,
you know, unless you're still running Jenkins, Selenium
probably isn't the option you wanna be going
with. I think it's very embedded in older
Java systems. I can this is my perspective.
Puppeteer is obviously the one that spun out
of Google itself, I believe, and Playwright is
what Microsoft decided to try and improve upon
it. So, you know, if you pick whatever
one you like.
Yeah. Puppeteer is the one I go to.
I think it's when you need help, which
I often do.
The examples are all online for Puppeteer, and
I like that. So
And Puppeteer is lighter. As far as we
know, Puppeteer
is lighter,
and PrevWrite send
bigger JavaScript, more complex things. I think it's
mostly because they try to be competitive with
more browsers than Puppeteers because you can run,
you pre write scripts on
Firefox too and some of the browsers. I
know. So I guess that's why
they have a different strategy using more JavaScript
with big scripts executing what they want.
All right. Awesome. All right. Let's change tack
a little bit before we get onto the
hands on demo, which I'm sure people are
excited for. But, you know, you've given us
a bit of history. You both worked together
now for eight years.
You just were doing, I think you said,
20,000,000
web page scrapes at one point. I don't
know if that was daily. I think you
said daily. Right? Yeah.
So I'm curious, obviously
you've been in this space for a while.
You've now got a new product. It's open
source. Do you have a history with open
source? Why did you go down this route?
Especially for something that is not not
not anyone could just sit down and go,
hey, I'm gonna write a new headless browser.
This is a very
hard challenge, a large project.
Why do it open source? I'd love to
learn more as well.
I think I'll I'll start and then, yeah,
add anything you want. But I think,
very simply, the
the de facto solution today is Chrome
and
headless Chrome is open source today.
To
disrupt
a space that's so well established
and offer something that isn't open source
is making life even more difficult in an
already difficult situation for one.
And then I think just all
the kind of
classic benefits of an open source project. I
mean, our target market is the developer community
and we've already had
some amazing contributions to the project and
Zig community
from, since we launched kind of properly the
beta version ended last year.
So I think we've seen that firsthand
despite obviously knowing it in theory beforehand.
Yep. And
if I can add,
think
the two things are
as
we were a potential user of LightPanda and
we will never
even try it if
it was
closed source, I think. So that's the main
reason.
But
also
because
we are under development, active development right now,
so the browser is not really
actually or in some cases,
not all, obviously. So it's maybe
more
understandable
for users to have some things not really
or not perfect
to use or to try because it's open
source
instead of
you if you get the closed source browser,
you expect to have something which is just
working.
And so
that's another point also. Yes.
Alright.
Last question. I'll keep it light so we
can get on to the hands on component.
Give me the history of the name.
What is a late panda?
Well,
it was mainly because
it was
brainstorming.
We
had some ideas,
but LightPanda was the coolest.
At the beginning, we had Had a benefit
of having a lot of available domain names.
Yes.
Also the Not a bad way to do
it, right? The Firefox,
I believe is
a red panda. Yes.
Which is also
known as a light panda. No, it's just
a red panda.
Yeah. Is that right? Yeah.
Yeah.
It's quite fun to play around with the
mascot though. This is my latest creation. I
don't know if you can see.
Alright.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing. I think we
should show people then
what LightPanda is, how to get started, what
it can do. So, Pierre, if you could
please
share your screen and we
will take a look. Sure.
So
do you see my screen? Yeah. We do
now. Thank you. Take it away.
So
as I said, we are under
heavy,
heavy development. So we don't have actually
a release tag,
but we are building the
browser
every night. So you can get the last
version
on the nightly
release on the GitHub
repository
where you can, well, just download the
last version
of the browser.
So I will do that.
Yeah.
So now you just have to
allow execution
on it.
You have two
currently, you have two ways to
use the browser.
The first one is
just a way to
fetch a web page
in your
CLI and
like you will do with
but
at the difference of with curl, we will
fetch the HTML and execute and fetch the
resource, the script resources and then execute the
whole JavaScript.
So
I'm
using
right now a local
web page
we are using
to demonstrate the browser. So that's a fake
e commerce page,
a product page.
So
we can try it by using,
like, Panda with
the fetch subcommand.
And then
I will just
add the dump option to ask LightBandA to
write the final HTML
in the
standard output.
And
what I will do,
I will save the results.
Oh, sorry. I forgot the URL, of course.
And I will save the HTML
in a file.
And it doesn't work.
Interesting.
What I do wrong
Is my ah, okay.
Sorry.
So let's start from the beginning.
I will start my
web server. It will be better.
So into my demo, I have a a
Go
web server.
Sorry.
Okay.
So
okay. Better.
I will try. Okay. Good. So here we
can see in the log
well, we have
oh, yeah. Sure.
Let me do that.
No.
How can I do that?
Come on. Okay.
Is that better?
Okay.
So here, yeah, what we can do is
we have
a telemetry
just to,
well,
to have
feedback from
binary usage,
but you can disable it using
an env
variable.
And then we have the log.
So the first log is to fetch the
first web page.
And then after
getting it and parse the HTML,
we get the browsers
fetch the
external resources. So here we have a script.
Js we want to execute.
And the script.
Js also
do some XHR
request,
want to get reviews
and want to get products details.
So
if
I look at the results
here,
Yeah.
So here I can see the results
of what we fetched.
So
we didn't
have
the CSS display here, but we have all
the information we wanted. So
here we have the the product name and
etcetera, the things, the reviews also.
So
we get the final HTML
with the
the
JavaScript results on it.
In comparison,
if I do the same with, let's say,
curl.
So
in that case of it, curl only
dumped the original HTML.
So it didn't,
of course,
run the JavaScript.
So we don't have the etcetera changes
loaded.
So that was the first
example.
So first way to use basically
LightPanda.
And
the another, I will say,
classic way to do that is to use
the
CDP
server.
So let's try that.
So if I have
Here in demo, I have some preparatory scripts.
One of them is CDP.
Js.
So this preparatory scripts
will just
run
some load of the page
to test it. So it connects to
one browser
URL
to the CDP server.
No, sorry, it's different here. So it connects
to the WebSocket's
CDP server
on the browser and fetch
the web page here, which is my local
server here. And by default, it
does the fetch
100 time.
So nothing fancy. It's per picture.
We have just a loop here. And on
each loop,
we create
a browser context, which is basically
a tab in the browser.
And then we navigate
into the
product web page.
And we are waiting for the
product price.
Yeah, we are waiting for the product price
and get it,
if I'm not wrong.
Well, yeah, we are checking it's loaded
and we are checking also that the reviews
are loaded. So to be sure that the
page,
the browser displays is the correct we want.
And we are extracting
some
data,
the
name, the price description of the product,
the related
products
also, and the reviews.
But we don't display them.
We just try to
We make some tests just to be sure
that
we get the data.
And finally, we display
results.
Well, we store the time
we used to
do the loop and at the end of
the process, just
display the average time, the min, the max.
So that's the
basic script we want to execute
to test.
So
I can run LightPanda
with the
serve
subcommand just to start the CDP web server.
I can also
add the port option, sorry,
to define another
point. But by default,
it's the 9,222.
It's a classic
port number
for
the browser CDP.
So if I run
my computer script using node,
so here we display a dot each time
we load
and we loop into the
page.
And
here we have
the
average time, which is
one,
sorry,
seventeen
milliseconds.
And just to compare, if you want to
do the same thing using Chromium,
you can run it with the headless new
option,
which run
the browser as headless,
and you will define
the remote debugging port, which will
enable the
CDP server, the exposition of the CDP server
from the Chromium browser and lets you connect
using
your
script.
And
because
Chrome doesn't
use just you have to
give the full URL
to connect
directly in the webs on the web server.
So
I registered an example.
What is it?
Browser,
WS.
Not sure.
That was wrong. Sorry. I will run LightBandA.
Let me
check the
name.
Its
browser address.
So here we can see
visually the difference
of speed
with Chrome,
is
slower.
Yes.
But it makes sense because
we are doing less
work, obviously. We don't,
of course,
do any rendering, graphical rendering of page.
So it takes time, but we don't also
load images,
we don't
decompress
images,
and that's a lot of work Chrome is
doing and we don't. That's also explain why
we could
be faster
than it.
So
I wouldn't say Chrome is slow. That's that's
not true. But we can skip a lot
of users' work in this case and so
save a lot of time this way.
I guess it comes down to your your
use case, right, and what people are trying
to do. Yes. There there's a large subset
of acceptance test and and synthetic testing that
doesn't need CSS and all of that other
stuff that comes with it. And keeping those
fast
is gonna save companies money, especially in their
CICD pipeline or or even locally when they're
running their testing, want this to be fast.
Sure. We we do have a question
in the from the
comments in the audience here from doctor.
I was curious if you could run both
of those CDP scripts against LightPanda and Chromium
again, but while running htop so we can
see the kinda the usage
of,
you know, Chromium versus LightPanda, if you're happy
to do that. Oh, yes. I can. Oh,
sorry. I stopped the screen sharing. My bad.
No. It's alright.
Yes.
How can I do that?
It's a good question.
I'm not sure. Well, we can try it.
If I run htop,
but
what I can do So it's F3, you
can search for well, it's gonna show you
your actual Chromium and not just the htop.
Yes.
That's a good point. But what I can
do instead,
maybe,
I can show you a bit an idea
of the
memory consumption,
but it's about memory, not CPU.
So to just give you
another idea,
let's say if I use the
It's time. V, I think.
So
oh,
okay. Now you have to change that UUID
again.
Yeah.
Oh, come on.
Okay. So I will run
Chrome
on it.
Oh, yeah. I could reduce the number of
loops,
not the loop but
In fact,
so here
we can see,
okay, we use something like
gigabytes
of memory at maximum.
And
if I run
LightPanda
Oh, sorry. I have to
use the
user
in
time
today.
I was,
yeah, it was
bigger here,
so we have,
okay, 60 megabytes
in this case. But we have,
in fact, the most of them
Is that correct?
No.
What are We introduced a new
options. I will find it exactly.
But
we
are reusing
currently the same,
well,
in V eight, you can start a V
eight engine and then you can create isolates
to
run code on
isolation into the V eight engine. So
currently we
changed
a
bit our
architecture
recently to reuse
the same
V eight engine started with
the browser, but using a new isolate per
page we are navigating.
And by default,
for now, we don't
run
the
garbage collector into the
Well, by default, we don't
give an option to the V eight to
run the garbage collector. And by
enabling
GC hints,
we are saying to
V eight
when we change the pages,
it could run Garbage Collector to save
memory. And so if
I will run the same tests
with this option,
It's a bit it could be a bit
slower,
but yes, you save
more
memory
this way. So
we were 200
megabytes using
Chrome.
And with this
gcints
options,
you are something like 21,
20 two megabytes with LightBandA.
So,
yeah,
But it's not CPU
usage.
I don't
really know
the difference between
LightBandA and
Chrome in CPU usage.
Since we are doing less work, I hope
or I expect
we use less CPU
but I
have no proof actually.
Nice.
Well, doctor seems happy with that at least.
Glad we could help.
Now, obviously,
you know, you're very diplomatically said here that,
you know, Chromium is different. It's doing a
whole lot more. LatePanda is very opinionated on
on what it's trying to do. So maybe
we could help people understand
the specific use cases when to reach for
LatePanda over using something like Chromium. I'm
assuming, you know,
this is aimed at front end developers built
in React applications and Vue applications. What's their
use cases? There's also the data collection sites
and OpenAI and AI agents and all this.
Like, When should people go for LightPanda?
When it works?
Well,
I want to show that
after I think. Yeah, I think, well, the
first question is if you need
visual rendering
or graphical rendering,
of course, you can't use LightPanda at all.
So if you need to do screenshots,
PDF of your page, of things like that,
It will not work with LightBandA.
And then,
theoretically,
in ideal world,
everything else will be okay.
Well, no, sorry.
The other point is if
you have issues with,
let's say,
fingerprinting,
things like that,
I think currently LightPanda
will not help you at all because
we are a different browser and we are
easy to fingerprint differently.
So
we'll be detected immediately. So if
you are in this use case, you
are better using right now
Chrome.
And
for the other use case, theoretically,
you could use LightPanda for everything else.
But
today is a bit early,
I think,
because
our main challenge actually
Well, we have many challenges,
but one of the main challenge is to
implement all the web APIs
required to run JavaScript
around the web.
And currently, we don't have all the support
of all of this, of course, but we
try to improve it every day.
So depending of the use case, I would
suggest you to
give a try to LightPanda,
see if it work in your case.
And if it is
good,
you use it. But
in other case, maybe you should retry later.
That's the point, yeah, I think.
Yeah. Does V eight support WebAssembly or is
that something that you would have to build
separately into your browser?
You mean executing WebAssembly?
Yeah. Is that a V eight concern or
is that something else?
Well,
V eight,
as far as I know, yes, we can
execute it directly into
V eight, but we have to bind correctly.
Let's say if
currently if a web page
offers a WebAssembly script,
we will have to
just bind
the source to execute it on the VA.
That's not the case actually.
But
I think it's not hard to do.
I hope so.
Alright. So
before I I throw some more questions at
you, was there anything else you wanted to
show? Oh, yeah. Just well, an example of,
well, a real
world
things, let's say.
So
what I wanted to show you. Oh, yeah.
For example, if you are trying to fetch
a page, let's say, if you want if
you want to use a DuckDuckGo to search
something
like Panda, for example.
So if you're trying it
with
the browser right now,
h
t
m l.
So here is an example of
things that could,
that goes wrong.
Here, for example, we have
a JavaScript failing
due to some reason.
I don't know exactly. Here we have another
one which fails because
match media
doesn't exist in our browser.
So here is ESMOBILE.
So
depending on the
JavaScript,
at the first issue,
it will stop executing
with an error.
So here you can see that in real
world, we are missing
a lot of web APIs, in fact.
But depending of data
you want or what you want to do
and depending of the,
let's say,
the
final results, it could be an issue or
not. In this case,
I think it's an issue.
Let's say the result in the browser. Let's
see the result.
So
here we can see we have nothing at
all.
What we have in the Nothing? That's where?
Oh
no, sorry. I forgot the option to jump
the page, usually.
Would explain the nothing. Yeah.
But
oh.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Okay. So it's we have not such more.
So we have only the
we have only the, yeah, basic HTML, I
don't know what.
And something interesting could be to compare which
with curl if we, let's say,
if we just have
the initial
HTML of if we have some difference. That's
that's not the point here.
So we did the code. It will not
work. I know that already that with Google,
currently,
it will not work too.
But I try with Bing.
And
Oh, I have to
use the Oh, not exactly.
I didn't have to use
the whole
URL,
Because there is some idea. I don't know
why. Never mind. So, if I try this
one.
So, I think on the
thing.
Again, we can see we still have some
URLs
on one JavaScript,
maybe.
What the results of that?
Okay. In this case, I have
a result. And just to compare because
if results are just sent
immediately, I mean, without JavaScript,
this is not a real proof or not
really interesting comparing this curve.
I mean, there's some CSS there, right?
That's
Maybe there are Well, depending of how
the CSS is declared in the HTML, my
browser here,
Chrome,
can fetch it and apply it. But that's
a good point. Maybe it does the same
with the JavaScript also.
Let's see. Can I
just
disable
JavaScript execution here?
Where is it?
Let me
I
know where is it in Firefox,
but not
in Chrome, actually.
Here, I can disable JavaScript.
Okay.
So
without JavaScript execution, I have some results.
If I do the same with curl
okay.
Nope. It's not
a good address.
Oh, I have results too. So
Okay, not interesting in fact. So yeah.
Okay, Bing just send back the results. That's
a good thing.
So yeah,
let's say that in real world, we
still have many,
well, web APIs to implement.
So you could have a lot of troubles
actually using LightPanda. It's not really ready right
now,
at least for most use cases. But in
some specifics,
it could work, in fact.
But we are working hard on it and
we are trying to, obviously,
improve that support to be able to
run more JavaScript and
having good results on more websites.
Are currently
integrating
the click.
And just to be
clear on that also,
there are both sides of implementation
we have to do. On JavaScript
side, we have to implement web APIs
from the browser. That's one big
challenge on one side. But on the other
side, we have also to
implement
CDP
commands.
We talked about
PrevWrite at the beginning, and that's also where
we have to improve things to be more
compatible with clients, depending on how they are
using
CDP protocol actually.
When it comes to the
hold on. I'll move his back over.
Yeah. So when it comes to those APIs,
right? You know, let's assume I'm testing
the Rawkode Academy platform,
and I wanna do some sort of logins
there. Do I have access to local storage,
the web SQL?
How much of that works right now in
the?
How much, I don't know.
We have some,
let's say, we have basic implementation of web
storage actually,
but it's hard to give you
a number. We
are using
the web platform test,
which is
common
HTML tests to
run on browsers. That's something which is standardized
and
we are trying to run the browser against
this test. So we are tracking
improvement on it,
But I don't have real
numbers to do that to answer in fact.
Okay.
I mean, think this is still a very
young project. It's an exciting project. I think
the value proposition is clear to the people
watching it, and it's a good way to
get involved if you've never written any Zig
before and you want to. Go check out
the repository and look for issues and and
and get committed.
But as we kinda mentioned earlier, this is
an an open source project. Right? And unfortunately,
money doesn't grow on trees. Open source has
to be sustainable.
I'm assuming
you just have a company that you're you're
trying to make successful with this product. So
maybe you can share a little bit of
light into
the roadmap for Light Panda as an open
source project, but also where you are taking
this as a company in order to be
a sustainable and long term business.
Yeah.
So
as you said, it's still super young. Our
big focus at the moment is
getting the browser to a point where it
can be used
reliably
in production.
And
we
we have a couple of
obvious ways that we'll build the business around
that.
Main one is obviously a cloud office.
We want the people to be able to
host it themselves if they want to. And
that's why it's open source, but
that's like, know, the case for every
use case out there.
We do have a, that's in beta at
the moment and it runs on Chrome and
like pandas that you can sign up on
our website
get a test taken for that. And
then we're also thinking about how we can
build
native
AI features into the browser itself
to
enable,
for example, but this is just more of
an example to illustrate the point, but to
enable LLM's, for example, to
and there are there are a ton of
tools doing this kind of thing already, but
they're building on top of of Chrome.
So,
having a version of the browser, which can
kind of take that a step further because
we control the whole code base to enable
the
structure of the webpage, for example, to be
controlled by an LLM
deeper down the stack as it were.
And then that'd be like a a kind
of on premise version of the browser or
a premium version if you like.
Okay.
And the roadmap for open source, I'm assuming
your heads are just down focusing on that
web compatibility and those conformance tests. Right? Like
Yes. That seems to be the the main
objective. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Yes. It is definitively.
How big is your team?
We are six at the moment, but Six.
Growing growing pretty fast.
I the good news, I guess, is that
kind of conservatively,
I think a lot of the hardest work
is kind of behind us. So as you
say, it's kind of just heads down. We
know what needs doing and we're
doing it. So we're pretty optimistic.
And yeah, like any and all feedback from
the community is super valuable as well. It's
one of the huge benefits of it being
open source as we get to hear from
people about, you know, these random
cases that are actually working in production already.
There may be some that there's really not
that big of a lift for us at
this point.
Yeah. I'm I'm sure it won't be long
until someone is using the CDP and, like,
Panda to order their Domino's pizza. And that
seems to be one of the first things
that people like to hack on.
Awesome. Well, thank you so much for taking
time out of your day
for guiding us and sharing more about LightPanda
and even getting hands on and showing us
how it works. Is there anything else that
we haven't covered that you would like to
share with the audience before we wrap this
up?
I don't think so from my side. Thanks
so much for for having us and giving
us the platform.
Yeah. Yeah.
Thank you very much
for the invitation.
Alright. Well, thank you again to the people
that watched us. You know, go check out
the project, open issues, contribute where you can,
and let us know how you get on.
Feel free to drop your comments and questions
into the comment section, and we'll do our
best to answer them whenever we can.
Have a great day. Thank you again, and
I'll see you all soon. Until next time.
You. Bye. Bye bye.
You make this happen. Fill the stream with
light.
We dove in deep with LightPanda speed and
grace.
That ZigBilled browser finding its own space.
Saw how it works,
how fast it really flies.
Reflected
in our guests' insightful eyes.
They showed the way,
the future looking fast.
That inspiration
surely gone to last.
Yeah. The stream is over,
but the journey's not.
Subscribe and follow,
give it all you've got.
We'll be right back before you know it,
friend.
More tech adventures
that will never end.
So join us next time Same cool place
to be
Right here at Rawkode
Academy
Yeah Thanks, Pierre Thanks, Pierre And Katie And
Katie. And thank you watching. Thank you watching.
And we'll see you next
time.
Rawkode
signing off.
See you soon.
Keep learning.
Keep coding.